༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཨ་མས་སྨན་ཁང་ལ་ཁྲིད་བྱུང་།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽གཞན་པ་གཅིག་ལ་མི་འདུག གཞན་པ།
[པད་ཤག་]སྤྲད་ས་གཅིག་ལ་འདུག་འོ་དེ།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཡོད་(བ)། ངའི་ཨ་མས་རྔན་པ་ཉོས། རྩེད་མོ་རྩེ་ག་ཁྲིད་བྱས་སོང་།
དྷ་ཤོད་ལ། མོ་ཊ་ད་རྟ་ད་༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཡོད་(བ)།
Jump Jump བྱས་བསྡད་ཡིན།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽མར་ཡི་གེ་བཏང་ག་ཕྱིན་ཡིན། འོ་དེ་ཨ་མས།
རྩེད་མོ་རྩེ་༼ཡ་༽ཉོས་སོང་། ཞི་མི།
པང་པང་བྱེད་༼ཡ་༽ཞི་མི་ཟིན་སྐྱ།
ཨ་ཅག ལོ་བཞི།
ང་ངང་པ་སྒྲུང་གཅིག ༼ཨ་ནས་༽བྱ་དེ་ཡོད། ནང་ལ།
ངང་པ་དེ་ཉི་གདུགས་༼ཁེར་༽ནས།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽རྔན་པ་བླུག་ས་དེ་ཡོད་(བ་)༼ཁེར་༽ནས་འགྲོ་བསྡད་བསྡད་འདུག ༼ཨ་ནས་༽མར་མཆོང་བསྡད་བསྡད་འདུག
༼ཨ་ནས་༽བྱ་དེ་གཅིག་ལ་ཡོད་(བ)།
ག་རེ་བྱས་འདུག་ལབ་ན།
བྱ་དེ་གཅིག་ལ་ཉི་གདུགས་གཅིག་ལ་སྤྲད་བསྡད་བསྡད་འདུག
༼ཨ་ནས་༽
འཁྲུག་པ་རྒྱག་བྱེད་༼གི་༽འདུག
འཁྲུག་པ་རྒྱག་གི་མེད།
ང་
པོ་པོ་རྨོ་མོ་ཡོད་(བ)།
པོ་པོ་གཅིག་དེ་གཞས་བཏང་གི་༼ཨི་འདྲས་༽སེ་༼ཨི་འདྲས་༽བྱེད་༼ཡ་༽གཅིག་འོ་དེ་པོ་པོ་གཞས་བཏང་བསྡད་འདུག
༼ཨི་འདྲས་༽བྱེད་༼ཡ་༽དེ།
རྨོ་མོ་གཉིད་ཁུག་བསྡད་༼ཞག༽
[མེ་ཀི་]ཟ་༼ཡ་༽དགའ་པོ་ཡོད་རེད།
མཚམས་མཚམས་འབྲས་དགའ་པོ་ཟ་༼ཡ་༽ཡོད།  ང་[མེ་ཀི་]གཅིག་པོ་གཅིག་ཟ་༼ཡ་༽དགའ་པོ་ཡོད།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ང་
ཟིང་སྐྱ་ཞི་མི་ཡོད་(བ)། འོ་དེ་ཁ་སང་སྨན་ཁང་ལ་ཉོས་སོང་།
རྩེད་མོ་
ཁོང་གཉིས་དང་ཁོང་ཚོ་ཡོད་(བ་)ཆུང་ཆུང་རེད།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཡོད་(བ)། མཁའ་འགྲོ་དེ་ཞོན། པུ་གུ་ཆུང་ཆུང་དེ་ཞོན་བྱེད་༼གི་༽ཡོད་རེད།
དེ་པུ་གུ་ཆུང་ཆུང་ཞོན་ས་རེད།
པུ་གུ་ཆུང་ཆུང་ཞོན་༼ཡ་༽དེ་ཡོད་(བ་)དེ་རེད།
མེ་ཏོག མེ་ཏོག་ཡོད་(བ་)ང་མཉམ་དུ་རྩེད་མོ་རྩེ་༼ཡ་༽དགའ་པོ་ཡོད་རེད།
མིག་མཐོང་གི་འདུག
གཞས་ཡོད་རེད།
ང་རོགས་པ་མཉམ་དུ་རྩེད་མོ་རྩེ་གི་ཡོད། དེ་ནས་རྔན་པ་ཟ་༼གི་༽ཡོད།
སྤོ་ལོ། ཐག་མཆོང་
༼ཨ་ནས་༽སྐོར་ར་རྒྱག་༼ཡ་༽༼གི༽
ཨ་འདྲས་༼ཨི་འདྲས་༽བྱེད་༼ཡ་༽དེ།
ང་ཚོ་སློབ་གྲྭ་ཡོད་རེད། བཞི་ཡོད་རེད།
གཅིག་སྐོར་ར་བྱས།
ངའི་སློབ་གྲྭ་ལ་ཁྱི་ཡོད།
སློབ་གྲྭ་
ཆུང་ཆུང་གཅིག་ཡོད་རེད།
རྫུན་མ་ལབ་ཀྱི་ཡོད་རེད།
རྫུན་མ་རེད། རྫུན་མྲ
དངོས་གནས་རེད།
ང་སྒྲུང་གཅིག་བཤད་༼ཡ་༽ཡིན། སྒྲུང་མེ་ཏོག་ཁ་གྱི།
༼སྔན་མ་སྔན་མ་༽མེ་ཏོག་གཅིག་ཡོད་རེད།
མི་དེ་མེ་ཏོག་བཀོག་ནས་༼ཨ་ནས་༽རྒྱ་གར་དེས་མི་ལ་རྡུང་པ་རེད། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཡོད་(བ)།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ངུས་རེད།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཡོད་(བ)།
མི་དེ་
༼ཨ་ནས་༽བྱེ་མ་ལེབ་ཟིན་ག་འགྲོ་རེད། བྱེ་མ་ལེབ་ཟི་ཐུབ་ཡོད་མ་རེད། རྩི་རྩི་ཟིན་ག་འགྲོ་རེད། ཟིན་ཐུབ་ཡོད་མ་རེད
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཡོ་བ།
དགའ་ཤོ་ལབ་ན་།
མི་དེ་ཡོད་(བ)།
དོམ་ཟིན་ཐུབ་ཡོད་མ་རེད། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽མོ་ཊ་གཏང་ཤེས་ཀི་ཡོད་མ་རེད། མོ་ཊ་གཏང་(ར)། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽མར་རིལ་རེད་(ད་)(ར)།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཁྲག་དོན་རེད་(ད)་འོ་ཡ། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཡོད་(བ)།
མི་གཅིག་ཡོད་(བ་)ངུ་ཡི་རེད།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཡོད་(བ)། ག་རེ་བྱས་ལབ་དགོས་བས། མ་དེ་ག་རེ་བྱས་ནས།
སུས་ཤོག་ལབ་འདུག་ལབ་རེད་(ར)།
ག་རེ་བྱེད་༼གི་༽ཡོད་ལབ་སོང་ཡོད་(བ)། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཡོད་(བ)།
དུག་སློག་གཅིག་ཆུ། དུག་སློག་ང་ལ་སྤྲད་ད་ལབ་རེད་(ད་)(ར)། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽དེ།
དེ་ཅ་ལག་དེ་ག་རེ་བྱས་ནས་༼ཁེར་༽རེད་ལབ་རེད་(ད་)(ར)།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཁྱི་དེ་ག་རེ་བྱས་ནས་ཡོད་ལབ་རེད་(ད་)(ར)། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཡོད་(བ)། ཁྱི་དེ་ག་རེ་བྱས་ནས་ཡོད།
༼ཁེར་༽ཡིན་པས་ལབ་རེད་(ད་)(ར)།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཡོད་(བ)།
མི་གཅིག་གད་པ་དེ་ཁ་ལག་ཟ་བསྡད་ཡོད་རེད་(ད)།
ཁ་ལག་ཟ་ཚར་ནས་གད་སྙིགས་མོ་ཊ་སླེབས་ཡོད་མ་རེད་(ད)།༼ཨ་ནས་༽གད་སྙིགས་མོ་ཊ་འགྲོ་ཚར་ནས་ཡོད་(བ)། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽
ང་ཚོ་ག་རེ་བསྡད་ཡོད་ལབ་(ར)། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཡོད་(བ)།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽སོ་སོ། གད་པ་ཚུར་ཤོག་ལབ་རེད་(ད)།ང་ཚོ་མཉམ་དུ་ཕྱགས་དགོས་ལབ་རེད་(ད)།ཡ་ཡ་ལབ་རེད་(ད)།
ཡོད་(བ་)༼ཨ་ནས༽།
སྤོ་ལོ་མཉམ་དུ་རྩེ་ག་ཤོག་དང་ལབ་རེད་(ད)།ཡ་ཡ་རྩེ་དགོས་་ཨ་ལབ་རེད་(ད)།
སྐར་མ་གཅིག་སྒུགས་ཨ་ལབ་རེད་(ད)།ངས་སྤོ་ལོ་༼ཁེར་༽ནས་ཡོང་དགོས་ལབ་རེད་(ད་)(ར)།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཡོད་(བ)། མཉམ་དུ་རྩེ་དགོས་ཨ་ལབ་རེད་(ད་)(ར)།
ག་རེ་བྱེད་༼གི་༽ཡོད་ལབ་ན།
དེ་སྦག་སྦག་དེ་ག་རེ་བྱས་ནས་ཁྱེར་ཡིན་པས་ལབ་རེད་(ད་)(ར)།
ག་རེ་བྱས་ལབ་ན།
ང་ལ་སྦག་སྦག་གཅིག་སྤྲད་དང་ལབ་རེད་(ད་)(ར)། སྤྲད་བཅུག་༼ཡ་༽མིན་ལབ་རེད་(ད)།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཡོད་(བ)། ངུས་རེད་(ད)།ང་ཡོད་ལབ་རེད་(ད)།༼ཨ་ནས་༽མོ་རང་ལ་སྤྲད་ཡོད་མ་རེད་(ད)།
གཅིག་མ་གཏོགས་ཡོད་མ་རེད་(ད)།༼ཨ་ནས་༽
སྤྲད་ཡོད་མ་རེད་(ད་)(ར)། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽འགྲོ་རེད་(ད་)(ར)།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ག་རེ་བྱས་རེད་ལབ་ན།
འོ་དེ་ཞེད་སྣང་ཚ་པོ་མེད་[འཇོག་]སླེབས་རེད་(ད)།༼ཨ་ནས་༽པག་ལབ་ནས་རྡུང་།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ག་རེ་བྱས་ནས་ཁྱེད་རང་ཇག་མ་གྱོན་ཡིན་པས་ལབ་རེད་(ད་)(ར)། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽སྦག་སྦག་དེ།
སྦག་སྦག་ག་རེ་བྱས་ནས་ཁྱེར་ཡིན་པས་ལབ་རེད་(ད་)(ར)།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཡོད་(བ)། བྱེ་མ་ལེབ་གཅིག་སླེབས་རེད་(ད)།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ནང་ལ་ལོགས་སླེབས་ཡིན།